hello everyone in
live broadcast understanding of the icy
HQ two key validation characteristics to
be considered for quality critical
applications I am Cindy Valdez
elaborates and I'll be your moderator
for today's event the work of IC h has
significance for pharmaceutical
manufacturers globally presented as part
of the Beckman Coulter life sciences
virtual tradeshow event this webinar
will address the key validation
characteristics to be considered for
quality critical applications according
to IC HQ two guidelines specifically for
online TOC analyzers the Beckman culture
life sciences virtual trade show is a
leading online home of live and
on-demand webinar programs available for
viewing any time other webinars in this
series cover topics such as flow
cytometry centrifugation particle
counting and characterization liquid
handling and robotics and nucleic acid
sample preparation before we begin I'd
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located at the
lower left of the presentation window
Tyger questions into the box that appear
on the screen will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also notice you're
viewing this presentation in a slide
window to enlarge that window just click
on the screen icon located on the lower
right if you have any trouble hearing or
seeing the presentation click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use that Q&A
button and let us know you're having a
problem I'd now like to introduce
today's speaker Tony Harrison Tony is a
senior marketing manager of Beckman
Coulter Tony earned a bachelor's degree
in electrical and electronic engineering
and is employed by Beckman cultural life
sciences as a senior merit marketing
manager he has held a convener ship of
ISO working group revising ISO one four
six nine eight part one and two for
microbial control and clean rooms and
was the UK's subject matter expert to
the ISO working group
who issued the 2015 revised versions of
ISO one four six four four part one and
two at the heart of the global GMP
regulations a little more about
recommend culture Beckman Coulter serves
customers in two segments diagnostics
and life sciences the company develops
manufactures markets products that
simplify automate and innovate complex
analytical testing more than two hundred
and seventy-five thousand Beckman
culture systems operate in both
diagnostics and life science
laboratories over seven continents
scientists use Beckman cultures life
science research instruments to study
complex biological problems including
causes of diseases and potentially new
therapies or drugs quality control
specialists use Beckman cultures
analytical instrumentation to maintain
quality control to the pharmaceutical
manufacturing industries about Roberts
Roberts is a leading scientific social
networking website which provides daily
scientific training news as science and
themed apparel as well as produces
educational virtual events and webinars
on the latest discoveries and
investments in science contributing to
the advancement of science through
content sharing capabilities lab roots
is a powerful advocate in amplifying
global networks and communities I'd now
like to turn over the presentation and
welcome you to all listening to Tony
Harrison welcome Tony well thank you
very much for that introduction and
welcome to everyone watching today I am
Tony Harrison from Beckman Coulter and
I'm going to talk today on validating
online TOC analyzers to allow their data
to be used for a batch release testing
in the place of quality control
laboratory toc testing so
a short presentation today it's about 20
minutes long and of course time for
questions at the end of it but to
introduce the topic first and then take
a brief look at what the TOC analyzers
are and how they measure then dive into
the IC hq2 characteristics and then I'll
demonstrate how a TOC analyzer can be
complied with IC HQ - and finally I'll
talk about how the P 8,700 TOC analyzer
from Beckman Coulter demonstrates
compliance to IC H Q - now as the
pharmaceutical industry seeks to reduce
the number and associated costs of
quality control laboratory tests
reliance on results from the TOC
analyzers for product release is
becoming more attractive especially the
online TOC on risers the International
Conference on harmonization the IC h
it's an expert working group with
representation from the United States
European and the Japanese Formica peers
in their harmonized tripartite guideline
IC HQ - which is titled validation of
analytical procedures they outline
characteristics for consideration during
the validation of analytical procedures
included as part of registration
applications submitted within the
European region Japan and USA this
presentation discusses how these
characteristics may be applied to online
total organic carbon analyzer to enable
them to be used to provide release test
data for water for injection and
purified water must take a couple of
minutes to go over TOC analyzer
technology and what they're actually
measuring TOC analyzers measure one of
the four key critical quality attributes
mandated by the farmer peers the other
three are inorganic contaminations which
typically measured using conductivity
endotoxins which are substances that can
act on the patient's hypothalamus and
give the patient a fever and microbes
which of course if that were rejected
into a patient could cause infection tsa
analyst bedside TOC analysis is a
nonspecific test what I mean by what I
mean by that is it is simply a measure
of the carbon the amount of carbon found
in the organic compounds in the water
they cannot tell you what type of
organic molecule is present a
pharmaceutical grade TOC analyzer uses
ultraviolet light to oxidize the organic
molecules present in the water to
release the carbon atoms and then
measures the difference in water
conductivity caused by the resultant
carbon dioxide TOC is to be calculated
according to the pharmacopoeias by
measuring total inorganic carbon and
total carbon and then subtracting one
from the other to calculate TOC so TC
minus T IC equals T OC all online
pharmaceutical grade TOC analyzers use
ultraviolet light to oxidize the organic
molecules and release the carbon in the
form of carbon dioxide the European
Chapter two point two point four four on
TOC analysis in the European
pharmacopoeia emphasizes the importance
of complete oxidation of the organic
contamination in order to release all of
the carbon atoms and get an accurate TOC
measurement if if the molecule is not
completely oxidized carbon molecules
sorry carbon atoms can remain trapped
inside the organic molecule and these
will not be measured so you're under
report.toc so if a TOC analyzer is to be
used for product release testing data
and it should follow the requirements of
I CH q2 in just the same way as a
laboratory QC TOC analyzer must this
shut this slide shows the
characteristics recommended in the IC HQ
to the guideline
I see HQ two covers three different
applications for analyzers analyzers
used for identification analyzed using
used for testing for impurities and
assay tests to use the analyzers used to
test purified water and water injection
foreign contamination naturally formed
the testing for impurities category I CH
q2 goes on to differentiate between the
validation characteristics required for
those TOC analyzers use for limit
testing of impurities and those used for
quantitative analysis of impurities now
online TOC analyzers have the purpose of
course of determining that the
Compendium limit of 500 ppb of TOC is
not breached but they're also used for
trending TOC levels and as such they
fall under the scope of the validation
characteristics required to both
quantitative testing and limit testing
analyzers now whilst robustness is not
listed in the in the list on the screen
here I see HQ 2 does recommend this
aspect of validation is tested during
initial qualification of the analyser
and it's suitable periods thereafter now
let's take a look at how POC analyzers
can be tested to demonstrate compliance
IC HQ 2 requirements IC h - sorry i
shakes q - suggests that accuracy may be
established by determining the closest
of agreement between the analyzer and an
accepted reference standard for toc
analyzers this can be achieved by
carrying out a calibration validation ie
by running certified TOC standards as
grab samples and determining if the
results provided by the analyzer are
within accepted or specified performance
limits naturally the analyzer should
have had a calibration adjustment before
carrying out this test I either normal
calibration adjustment procedure
recommended by the manufacturer should
have been carried out to make sure the
analyzer is accurate as possible
I see hq2 suggests accuracy accuracy
should be demonstrated using three
replicates each of three different
concentrations as is shown on this graph
now the power evasion of analyzers for
quantitation of impurities includes an
investigation of precision I CH q2
recommends the determination of
precision of a repeat reaper
repeatability we validated again using
three replicates each of three certified
standards at different concentrations it
also recommends that steps are taken to
reduce the opportunities for human error
to impact on intermediate precision
multi analyser such as automation of
standard operating procedures and
elimination of manual data entry and
manual calculations the specificity test
establishes the analyzer ability to
measure the analyte of interest in the
presence of potentially interfering
substances now in the case of a modern
purified water or water injection system
the challenged toc analyzers face is
that the toc levels are relatively small
often less than 30 parts per billion
whereas the levels of total inorganic
carbon and total carbon are
comparatively high somewhere between a
thousand ppb and 2,000 ppb is quite
common toc analyzers measured totally
inorganic carbon and total carbon and
they calculate the toc so small errors
in measuring the total carbon and the
inorganic carbon can lead to big errors
in the calculated toc now this problem
is most notable in toc analyzers that
have separate sensors to measure total
carbon and inorganic carbon in the
example shown on the screen here small
errors in the measurement of the total
carbon and total inorganic carbon lead
to a reported variation in THC which
could be anywhere between minus 30 ppb
and plus 50 ppb so you can see how small
errors in those measurements can lead to
big errors in the reported toc levels
as far as detection limits concerned the
farm expiry toc analyzers must have a
detection limit of less than or equal to
50 parts per billion of toc now the
validating such a low level of toc is
difficult using traceable toc standards
as these are generally not available at
such low levels equally attempting to
make your own toc solution at 50 ppb
it's just not practical it's too small
I see HQ to suggest alternative is to
calculate the limit of detection by
running multiple samples from a blank
toc solution now in the pharmacopoeias a
blank toc solution is defined as having
less than 100 parts per billion of toc
and then using the standard deviation
between the measurements to calculate
the limits of detection quantitation
limit has the same similar challenge as
limits of detection quantitation limit
is defined is the lowest level of toc
that the analyzer can accurately measure
and report toc values like the limited
detection this can be difficult to
establish using traceable certified
standards as these are generally not
available these very low levels so IC HQ
to suggest an acceptable method divide
this characteristic is by running
multiple analyses of blank samples and
using the standard deviation to count
calculate the quantitation limit now if
you looked at the two formulas wrong for
limited detection and woful limit of
quantitation you can see that the limit
of quantitation is approximately three
times the detection limit now as far as
linearities concerns you can use
calibration for this and there are two
types of calibration the international
standards organization ISO the defined
calibration as a validation of an
instrument against known certified
calibration standards a calibration
adjustment however using three search
for hydration standards can also be used
to determine determine linearity which
here on this slide
expressed as r-squared a pharmaceutical
grade toc analyzers are designed to
demonstrate that the 500 parts per
billion toc limit defined in the Formica
peers has not been exceeded
so the acceptable range of a
pharmaceutical toc analyzer is
established by confirming that the
analytical procedure provides an
exceptional degree of linearity accuracy
and precision when applied to samples
containing amounts of toc within or at
the extremes of the specified range of
the analytical procedure as a specified
maximum allowable toc level is 500 parts
per billion
then the linearity accuracy and
precision must be demonstrated around
this maximum 500 ppb point now the
robustness characteristic is used to
demonstrate the reliability of an
analyzer with respect to deliberate
variations in methods parameters now for
toc analyzers the United States and
European pharmacopoeia suggest that this
is established using the system
suitability test where the analyzers
response to toc standards in
deliberately varied organic materials is
tested to ensure there's no large
variation in reported toc results
solutions have easily oxidized sucrose
and difficult to oxidize bends going on
both containing 500 parts per billion of
carbon are analyzed on the toc analyzer
to demonstrate that the analyzer is
robust the reported results from both
the system suitability test solutions
must be within plus or minus 15% of each
other so let's finish off today's press
short presentation by showing how the
EPI 8,700 toc analyzer from Betancourt
can be shown to comply with the
requirements of IC hq2 so this is the
table of the characteristics from IC h
q2 and how the p80
700 can be demonstrated to be in
compliance the p80 700 is designed to
support compliant / HQ - a combination
of three calibration standards with
triple samples each satisfies the
requirements for accuracy repeatability
linearity and range whereas triple
samples from toc blanks satisfies both
the detection limits and the
quantitation limit calculations manual
data entry and manual calculations are
limited through eliminated sorry through
automated SOPs and robustness is
demonstrated through the mandated system
suitability test the p80 700 employees
are unique single sensor measurement
technology which allows the p80 700 to
maintain specificity and avoid any
interferences from high levels of CIC
now you should now be seeing an
opportunity to register to receive my
white paper on this topic on your
screens so that concludes my short
presentation today I'd be happy to take
any questions from the audience
thank you Tony for that informative
presentation and we will now start the
live Q&A portion of the webinar if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box but if you're on the screen
and click that send button will answer
as many questions as we have time for so
let's take a look at what our audience
questions the ones that are coming in
already Tony our first question is why
is it important to validate an online
POC analyzer - I see HQ - now thank you
for that question so basically if an
online analyzed data is to be used to
reduce the financial burden of QC
laboratory testing or by using it to
provide release data and really it
should be validated as completely as the
laboratory TOC analyzer would be so I
see HQ to provide sufficient evidence
acceptable to the regulator inspectors
from the United States the European and
the Japanese regulatory bodies allowing
the online analyzer data to reduce or
eliminate the need for QC lab toc
testing that's why it's important thank
you and our next question coming in how
does having single sensor technology
help the P 8700 avoid interference from
high levels of total inorganic carbon
well thank you for that one the issue
really is that a modern water treatment
plant using reverse osmosis to
manufacture the water tends to
concentrate the levels of carbon dioxide
dissolved in the water so they tend to
have elevated levels of total inorganic
carbon and the problem occurs in
analyzers that used to separate sensors
to measure total current and total
inorganic carbon we're a small drifting
collaboration between these two sensors
can lead to measurement errors which
will impact on the accuracy of the
reported or calculated total organic
carbon so what the P 8,700 does is it
traps an aliquot of the water sample it
measures the total inorganic carbon
using the sensor and then oxidizes a
sample and measures the total carbon
with the same sensor so any drift in
this single sensor calibration will
affect both total and inorganic carbon
and total carbon results equally so it
cancels out the effect of any drift
thank you and I want to thank our
audience today for tuning in to this
live webinar Tony we have one more
question coming from our audience how
does that pad seven-hundred avoid the
facts of human error on the intermediate
precision as mentioned in IC h q - thank
you for that one so yeah a human error
particularly in calibration and system
suitability tests is arguably the
biggest problem so the p80 eliminates
manual data entry and manual
calculations which are arguably to be a
source of human error in the QC world
the calibration and system suitability
standard bottles carry an RFID tag which
allows the P 8,700 to recognize the
standards and upload and read their
certified value and check their use by
date so that eliminates the manual data
entry and then the P 8700 has automated
SOPs programmed in to allow it to carry
out the prescribed tests such as
calculator calibration and system
suitability and then calculate
automatically the pass/fail result so
there's no manual data transcription of
results that data is exported via
ethernet using password-protected PDF
files that secure File Transfer Protocol
so we completely remove the opportunity
for human error thank you very much Tony
and would you like to go ahead and
provide the audience with some closing
remarks before we close today just to
say thank you to everybody for listening
to this short presentation I appreciate
it I hope you found it valuable thank
you and before I go I want to thank Rob
roots and our sponsor recommend Coulter
for making today's educational webcast
possible I'd also like to remind
audience members that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
at this month you will receive an email
from lab roots letting you know when the
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues whom you miss today's live
event that's all for now and thanks for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye bye thank you thank you bye bye